hallo und herzlich willkommen aus meinem
küchenfußboden ich weiß nicht warum aber
ich sitze hier einfach wahnsinnig gerne
also seid ihr herzlich eingeladen mit
mir hier auf dem fußboden zu setzen und
über grüne tomaten zu reden ich möchte
euch nämlich zeigen wie ihr grüne
tomaten so tomaten jetzt noch unreif an
euren pflanzen hängen nach heißen können
oder sie und werden und ihr bis
weihnachten noch eigene tomaten aus dem
eigenen garten essen könnt ich habe das
eben mal gegoogelt um zu gucken was da
so für informationen im internet zu
finden sind und da gibt es einige sachen
die ich absolut nicht unterschreiben
kann da steht zum beispiel mann soll
jede tomate einzeln in zeitungspapier
einwickeln habe ich noch nie gemacht ich
weiß nicht wieso man sich die arbeit
machen sollten weil es funktioniert auch
ganz ohne und da steht die dürfen auf
keinen fall im hellen gelagert werden
das stimmt auch nicht also wir lagern
unsere tomaten immer ganz normal bei
also jetzt nicht direkt am fenster aber
auch nicht im dunkeln
also es ist eigentlich sehr viel
einfacher als man so denkt formaten nach
reifen zu lassen und ich zeige euch
heute mal wie das so funktioniert
schauen wir mal gerade ins gewächshaus
weil ich glaube da hängt noch die eine
oder andere grüne tomaten an den
sträuchern die wir gerade die enten
können
[Musik]
hier habe ich noch ein paar tomaten
gefunden die an den sträuchern hängen
sobald es unter zehn grad ist für
mehrere tage
solltest du wirklich deine tomaten
ernten weil die an den sträuchern dann
nicht mehr nach reifen und die pflanzen
bekommen dann langsam aber sicher die
krautfäule und dann würden die tomaten
an den sträuchern einfach vergammeln das
wäre einfach zu schade wir noch
irgendwelche haben da oben da ist das
problem in luque klein bis zum große
tomatenanbau c't moment
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier kann man sich auch nicht gehen
lassen hat mir staffeln unsere grünen
geernteten tomaten sodass sie zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten reif
werden es ist nämlich so dass ihr kelter
du deine tomaten lagern desto langsamer
reißen sie nach und so kannst du dann
echt noch bis ende dezember immer noch
die nach gereiften tomaten essen da
musst du einfach mal ein paar orte
suchen in deinem haus oder in deiner
wohnung an denen unterschiedliche
temperaturen herrschen also bei 20 grad
reifen die innerhalb von ein paar tagen
nach dann kannst du die gleiche essen
und je kühler es ist also gefrieren
sollten sie nicht aber kühler ist desto
langsamer dauert ist wird alles
langsamer ist der reifungsprozess das
hier sind alles tomaten die schon vor
über einem monat geerntet wurden
mein frau hinter dir in diesen dieses
einer karosse herein gepackt ich weiß
auch nicht warum spielkind aber die sind
jetzt langsam reif um gegessen zu werden
und je nachdem wie hoch die temperatur
ist während du deine grünen geernteten
tomaten lagers kannst du das dann auch
takten also wir haben die zum beispiel
extra in die warme küche gelegt damit
sie schneller reifen und dann haben wir
eine andere portion von tomaten in den
kühlen vorgelegt damit sie da ein
bisschen langsamer nach reifen und wir
ungefähr noch bis weihnachten eigene
tomaten essen können hier ist es zb ein
bisschen kühler im flur und da reißen
die tomaten langsamer nach hier haben
wir auch ein paar hingelegt so dass wir
in unterschiedlichen stadien immer
wieder nach gereifte tomaten essen
können und du kannst sie wirklich
einfach auslegen also drückt kannst die
einfach da hinlegen und dann reifen die
danach schlägt manchmal noch ein
geschirrtuch unter falls eine dabei ist
die fouls so dass sie oberfläche auf der
die liegen nicht matschig wird aber
normalerweise passiert das nicht du
kannst ja alle angesetzten verletzten
tomaten vorher aussortieren
dann ist es gar kein problem also muss
die nicht in zeitungspapier einwickeln
und musste auch keine grosse arbeit
machen die reifen einfach so ganz normal
nach wenn du sie irgendwo hingelegt du
kannst deine grünen tomaten ja aber auch
sofort verarbeiten also du kannst du zum
beispiel chutneys draus machen das mache
ich auch gerne wenn wir ganz viele grüne
tomaten haben mach ich da gerne meine
stadt nicht raus wenn ihr noch andere
ideen oder rezepte habt vor ich mich
wenn ihren kommentar
ihr könnt mir auch mal schreiben wie ihr
das macht mit den tomaten nachreifen ich
mache da einfach kein großes ding gras
und das hat bisher immer funktioniert
also wir hatten noch nie irgendwie
probleme damit unsere tomaten auf die
art nach reifen zu lassen wenn ich hier
irgendwie blödsinn erzähle dann könnt
ihr mich dass ich gerne wissen lassen
ich bin immer offen neue sachen zu
lernen aber als ich das eben gelesen
habe dachte ich also bei uns
funktioniert auch sehr sehr gut ohne
diese ganzen sachen ist es auch möglich
nicht komisch